let's talk a little bit more about the
comparison between sn1
between sn1 and sn2 reactions and maybe
we can also talk about what type of
conditions make each one or the other
more favorable and especially the
solvent we've talked about it a little
bit but we'll go into a little bit more
detail so just as a bit of a review an
sn1 reaction you have a
you might have some type of a let me
just draw it like this so you'll have
some
some carbon that's attached to three
things i'm making these three things
just arbitrary colors they could be
other carbon ch3 it could be hydrogens
it could be other things
and then there it's also attached to a
leaving group
also attached let me do this in a color
that i haven't used yet in pink it's
also attached to a leaving group and
then you also have a nucleophile you
also have a nucleophile floating around
that'll be our nucleophile it has an one
excess electron has a negative charge
and an sn1 reaction the first step only
involves one of the reactants one of the
reagents that's why it's called sn1 so
in the very first step the nucleophile
just waits passively while the leaving
group leaves
so you have the leaving there may be
there's electron right there the leaving
group already has an electron it swipes
one so it has to be reasonably
electronegative and it swipes one from
that carbon and so once it does that our
situation will look like this
you have your substrate it now just lost
an electron it lost that electron so it
now has a positive charge let me have
that little trace of something let me
let me erase this right here so you
don't think that electron is still there
so it now has a positive charge the
leaving group which was neutral took an
electron so it now has a negative charge
the leaving group now took an electron
so it now has at least two valence
electrons there it has a negative charge
probably a lot more and then in the next
step this nucleophile so let me copy and
paste this
that's not what i wanted to do
let me copy and paste it again
so copy
and paste
okay so that thing that was waiting
patiently during the rate determining
steps is hey there's a carbocation there
i'm a reason i'm a nucleophile i'm not a
strong nucleophile in the case of an sn1
but i i like i still like giving away uh
electrons to nucleuses i love nucleuses
i see a
positive carbocation there well actually
a carbocation is positive by definition
so let me give let me give my electrons
to him
so let me give my electrons to him and
in the very last step we have a
situation
where
this guy let me copy and paste this
again
let me copy
and let me paste
that guy
is bonded to the nucleophile
is bonded to the nucleophile since the
nucleophile gave the electron to this
carbon the carbon doesn't have a charge
anymore and since the nucleophile lost
that electron it's now neutral
so you have it bonded to the nucleophile
and of course you have the leaving group
still here the leaving group still here
with a negative charge and we've talked
about well we've talked about we've
hinted at this a little bit but in order
for this step to happen with kind of on
its own with you know only this reagent
you know happening spontaneously to some
degree or for it to just happen and we
won't talk about the rates and it won't
necessarily happen fast but in order for
this to happen at all this has to be a
stable carbocation and we've seen before
that in order for this to be a stable
carbocation it has to be bonded to
things that are willing to lend it some
electrons so that it doesn't you know so
it's not super hungry for electrons in
order for that to happen this has to be
this carbocation right has to right here
has to be tertiary
tertiary is ideal and if tertiary
carbocation means that these three
things over here are all carbons or
carbon chains so ideally it would be
tertiary and secondary will also work if
at least if at least two of these guys
are carbon that'll also work if the
solvent is favorable if the environment
we're dealing with is a favorable
environment if only one of these were
carbons or so this is a primary
carbocation or this was a methyl
carbocation where nothing here is a
carbon
then you're unlikely to have an sn1
reaction now on the other side of the
picture sn2
sn2 reaction this is the one where you
have a super strong nucleophile or at
least a strong nucleophile and the whole
reaction happens in one step involving
both of the reagents
so you start here
you start here with your you have your
leaving group
the way you can think about sn1 the
leaving group is the thing that does
something first in sn2 it all happens at
once but the nucleophile is kind of the
aggressor it really wants to give away
it really it really wants to give that
electron away badly so in the very first
step it comes in here and gives it to
that carbon even though that carbon
didn't necessarily want it that badly it
might have a part it would have a
partial positive charge if this thing is
really electronegative it might be
hogging this electron already but i
think that it was already hogging now it
could say hey you already got an
electron i can take it from you and so
in literally one step we end up with
something like this
we end up with something like this
actually let me just redraw that so we
have our leaving group has left
our leaving group has left it's taken
the electron that the carbon didn't need
anymore so it now has it has this
electron and that one and maybe more
and it has a negative charge and now
this carbon
this carbon
it's attached to the blue thing i'll
just draw the purple thing
and maybe in back it's attached to the
orange thing let me do it draw it so you
see what i'm talking about
so the blue thing and then the purple
thing
and then nucleophile had come from the
other direction so now it's also bonded
to the nucleophile the nucleophile is
giving an electron so it loses its
negative charge and essentially the
negative charge gets transferred to the
leaving group which is able to take an
electron and then that carbon in the
middle stays neutral and we saw before
that this can only reasonably happen
with a strong nucleophile
that has to be a strong nucleophile and
there can't be a lot of steric hindrance
these things can't really block this
nucleophile from attacking so this will
work best in a this will work best if
this is a methyl
if this is a methyl or primary carbon
and if the conditions are just right and
if the nucleophile is strong enough
maybe
maybe secondary
maybe
second maybe a secondary carbon because
once you have too many carbons or big
carbon chains over here then it blocks
the nucleophile it cannot attack if
these are all hydrogens there's a lot of
space for this nucleophile attack if
only one of these are carbon still a lot
of space now that's just kind of a
general comparison and you know it gives
you some clues weak nucleophile you're
dealing with sn1 strong nucleophile sn2
if this is a tertiary or secondary
carbon so if it's bonded to a lot of
other carbons sn1 should be in your
brain if this isn't bonded to a lot of
carbons and you have a strong
nucleophile sn2 should be in your brain
and now the last thing you should have
to think about is the solvent itself
what are these reagents actually
dissolved in so let's think about it so
we definitely
in in either an sn1 or an sn2 reaction
we're dealing with things that have
charge and in general if you're dealing
with ions or things that have charge
they're going to be more soluble in
polar in polar solvents because the
charge likes to be around other things
with charge so that they can mix and
match so in both situations
in both situations you want to have
you want to have polar solvents
polar solvents in both situations and
you are familiar with polar solvents
examples of polar solvents are
well water is a polar solvent
h2o and it's polar because oxygen is so
electronegative it hogs electrons
it hogs electrons so you have a partial
negative
charge on the oxygen side and partial
positive charges on the hydrogen side
other example
or another example of a polar solvent
that you may have not seen before that
you may have not seen before
is
something like diethyl ether
so diethyl ether would look like this
ch2
ch3 ch2
ch3 and i know we haven't named ethers
yet let me write this this is die ethyl
diethyl let me make sure i get that y
right
diethyl this is diethyl ether and this
is a bit of reviewing this is probably
the best way to learn things as we learn
as we go
an ether is something that has a form
you have some carbon chain or some
you could call it a radical some some
group attached a carbon chain i guess is
the way my brain processes it to an
oxygen which is attached to another
carbon chain it doesn't have to be the
exact same one in diethyl ether it is
the same and you're literally just
saying diethyl you have two ethyl groups
attached to an ether ethyl is two
carbons so two carbons each oxygen two
more carbons diethyl ether and this is
also a this would also be a polar
solvent because oxygen is more
electronegative than carbon so you still
have this partial negative charge let me
do this in a different color on the
oxygen end
you still have your partial negative
charge on your oxygen end and you still
have a partial positive charge on your
carbon end so this is also a polar
solvent both of these are polar solvents
now the difference between these and
this will probably be a new term for you
is this
water and most types of alcohol some
things that have hydrogens that could be
knocked off this is a protic solvent
this is a protic solvent and protic just
comes from protons and that means that
if something is dissolved in this or if
you have a solution of this that these
hydrogens might be able to get knocked
off and you might have free protons
lying around because if let's say this
oxygen
swipes this electron from this hydrogen
if it swipes that electron from that
hydrogen then you have a situation where
you have o h minus
right the oxygen now has a negative
charge and this hydrogen all it had to
its name was that electron if you take
that away all it is is a proton so when
someone draws hydro h plus that
literally is a proton
that literally is a proton and this can
occur in water that you have some
protons floating around so water is
fundamentally a pro
a protic polar solvent
diethyl ether on the other hand it
doesn't have hydrogens that can be can
where oxygen can take its hydrogens away
the hydrogens here are all bonded to
carbon which is not that electronegative
so this is an aprotic solvent
let me draw this this is an a
this is an a
protic
a
protic
solvent
now let's think about whether an sn1 or
sn2 is better and well i already said
they're both good and you the both the
solvents have to be polar and that's
because we're dealing with charged
things in both reactions but which one
will be better so let me write this down
so in both situations we want a polar
solvent so let me write that down in
both situations
and i'll give you a hint one of them
will be good in a protic environment and
one of them will not be good in a protic
environment so an sn2 if you had let's
just think it through let's just not
memorize this if we had protons floating
around
if we had protons floating around in an
sn2 situation what is likely to happen
we have this strong nucleophile we have
this thing that wants to give away
electrons now it could give it away to a
carbon that might maybe have a partial
positive charge then the leaving group
could take it away
but what wants electrons more a carbon
that has a partial negative charge or a
proton something that has a full
positive charge well a proton would want
it more so if you had protons floating
around the nucleophile would just give
its electrons to the proton and the sn2
reaction wouldn't actually occur
the protons would take all the electrons
so you can't have protons floating
around you cannot have protons floating
around in an sn2 reaction it'll
then this carbon will never get the
electron the proton will take it so you
need an aprotic you need an a
protic
and a protic solvent so sn2 would work
well in diethyl ether if this is if this
is a weak if this is a sorry if this is
a strong nucleophile it's a solution in
diethyl ether and this we're all
hydrogens then you'd be just ready to go
for an sn2 reaction now on the other end
of this of the spectrum the key in an
sn1 reaction is that this carbocation be
stable and for a carbocation to be
stable
or actually even more important instead
of the carbocation being stable that's
dependent on it being a tertiary or
secondary carbon but in order for the
leaving group to be stable when it's
negative it actually would be nice if
there were some if there were some
protons available maybe it could give
electrons to the the to the proton maybe
it could bond with the proton so in this
situation the protons will actually help
stabilize the situation so in a polar in
an sn1 reaction the ideal is actually a
polar protic
protic
solvent so if you see a situation where
you have a secondary or tertiary carbon
it is a weak nucleophile you have a weak
nucleophile and you're dealing with a
polar protic solvent the most famous of
which is water but an alcohol would also
work then you should be thinking sn1 if
you see a strong nucleophile there's not
much steric hindrance there's space that
it can attack this is a methyl or a
primary maybe a secondary carbon and
it's happening in an aprotic
polar solvent like diethyl ether then
you know you're ready for an sn2